e
Montréal. Est-ce qu'on est
vraiment en ligne pour la très
longue série jusqu'à la coupe?
- Les partisans du Canadien
vont vivre pour une 7e fois
l'excitation d'une participation
à une finale d'association.
Une 7e fois depuis
la consécration des efforts
d'une équipe dirigée
par un entraîneur recrue.
- Ce sera la victoire
pour les Canadiens!
- Wouhou!
- Coupe Stanley
pour les Canadiens!
- Il y a 35 ans, le Canadien
de Jean Perron se rendait
jusqu'au bout.
La finale d'association
la plus récente remonte
à 2014, contre les Rangers.
Une blessure subie par
Carey Price freine l'élan des
Glorieux, battus en 6 matchs.
Un autre parcours
mémorable : celui de 2010.
Le printemps Halak.
- Jaroslav Halak!
- Inspiré par son gardien,
le Canadien élimine les Capitals
et les Penguins, avant d'être
blanchi à 3 reprises par les
Flyers et vaincu en 5 matchs.
Aujourd'hui, Montréal
est de nouveau emportée
par une frénésie inattendue
qui nous rappelle celle
de la Coupe Stabley 1993.
- Di Pietro maintenant, relais
jusqu'à Keen, à Di Pietro,
et le but de Dionne!
- Le Canadien avait surpris les
Nordiques, puis s'était offert
un balayage contre les Sabres.
En 2021, le Canadien renverse
Toronto, puis balaie les Jets.
Le scénario est similaire.
Le nouvel entraîneur Jacques
Demers mène son équipe
à la coupe Stanley
et cette chanson résonne
sans cesse dans le vestiaire.
♪ Nothing's gonna stop us now ♪
Jusqu'où ira le Canadien
de l'entraîneur recrue
par intérim Dominique Ducharme?
Et qu'ont en commun toutes
les meilleures performances
du CH durant ces 35 ans?
Chaque fois, le Canadien était
dirigé par un nouvel entraîneur.
Ici Jean-François Poirier,
Radio-Canada, M